do what i gotta do here
okay we'll open up the hearing for hb uh
the committee conference on hb1106
and what i'm going to do is go to the
senate there on this amendment here
because you really have us confused
on what this commission of demographic
trends out i mean where and whether this
even came to the house
thank you um representative
if i may speak for the senate
um in hb2 of last year
we removed an ongoing commission that
was crea that started in 2018
by we i mean we accidentally approved it
um when the office of strategic
initiatives split up into the department
of energy and business and economic
affairs
it was my understanding that they didn't
fund
it's been historically
they have not funded a position
for the state demographer that we
authorized in 2018
as a legislative body
and that authorization
also created the commission on
demographic trends and required some of
our state and agencies to create 10-year
current service budget so we can start
to look at a state
long term
so in the hb2 of last year
when i when we saw the
demographic commission line
i just assumed it was taking out the
funding for the state demographer as we
had done previously
however a representative brought it to
our attention
that it actually took away the entire
commission
and the commission has been meeting
it has four representatives on it has
governor appointees on it
and
myself as a senate appointee
and we've been meeting since 2018 um
kind of a hiatus in the covid times but
we didn't realize that we were not a um
ongoing commission any longer the lba
had been meeting with us they didn't
realize it and so i apologize for
sticking this on your bill
representative but um i tried to find
some place where i thought it wouldn't
be offensive to anybody but it's a
commission that is still meeting however
we should not be meeting because we're
not actually in statute any longer okay
so the hp2 it was in hb2 you're saying
but it just took it out
yes hb2 took it out without us realizing
it okay
did uh anyone else have anything on that
rich uh john
i think i'm good okay so i was a little
concerned because i wasn't didn't know
whether we had a house hearing on it but
since it was an hb2
i guess you had a house hearing on it in
2018 and we approved it then right um
but we just didn't realize that
when strategic initiatives split up they
just deleted the commission
and
the house didn't realize it the senate
didn't realize it the lba office didn't
realize it the governor was still
appointing
appointing members to the commission it
was representative horrigan that pointed
it out to me so
he was the only one in in the state
house that realized that it was not an
yes senator i'm just curious
uh
what's what's the mission of i mean
demographics can be huge
linda
so um in in in the amendment um the
oh wait that's yours sorry i'm trying to
i gave you a side by side there too by
oh yes sorry
so the duties of the commission is to
look at the
net migration goals of the state
um to
start to reque requires some certain
state agencies that will be impacted by
changes in demographics to look
out ten years versus just doing a
two-year budget so start to plan as a
state how we what what are the
challenges that we're going to be facing
like what are the bumps or declines in
funding that we're going to see coming
forward so that we can not be surprised
by budget issues or also that we could
challenge something saying why is your
budget increasing when we know that the
demographics in this
funding pool
are decreasing things of that nature so
it's it's more it's a it's a long-term
look at things and also a
um a better way for the legislature to
be informed of what this what the state
is going to be looking at long term
we have some very active
government governor appointees on it
it's
we don't get much attention but it's
really an interesting commission
and our goal is also to
be more interactive with the legislature
and we started to do that
um in early 2020 and then things kind of
stopped and
if i may yes
i know that new hampshire historically
as far as demographic trends
were very old state
but then i saw recently
that young people are moving or staying
in the state i'm not sure
but that would be a tremendous
demographic trend that affects housing
and affects
uh
you know if we're getting younger
that's a great thing
especially for health care and so forth
but in the in the we know we have a
housing crisis
and that impacts young people
uh but uh i i think there's a tremendous
need for that particularly in the area i
mean
like i said uh demographics is a big
subject or it can be you know you can
narrow it down but just in that one
demographic trend
it has long-term impact
to a lot of things that we do
i agree and it sounds like you would be
a great commission member
well i would be happy to
i i used to teach statistics so i enjoy
that that sort of numbers you know
but uh
um you know when it says i was confused
when it said
uh net migration goals and i said net
migration goals what the devil is that
you know
uh because
migration you know is
um
can mean a lot of things yes yeah it's
it's the
inflow versus outflow of population what
and births and
so
um yes okay um
linda
um erin i was wondering
you're going to put out a biennial
scorecard
what would that scorecard consist of
who's doing the scorecard and what are
you comparing it to so it
um thank you for the question that
biennial scorecard um the first one was
due in 2020 and unfortunately that's
when like at the end of 2020 and that's
when we shut down so we haven't actually
done that yet
but it would be ideally to highlight
some of the legislative legislation that
the commission
either
agreed with or advocated for um it would
be to know what we've identified as our
net migration goal and currently it's
going to be something along the lines
it's
something more vague to your point that
it could be anything and it would be to
meet the needs
of the population of our state because
right now we don't have enough people to
so i i can't tell you what would be in
that scorecard as although i um
currently chair the commission i
probably will not be cheering it again
since i'm not running again
um
oh it would be the commission that will
put it together okay are there any other
questions
end here and it's november 1st 2022 is
what it's going to take effect it's 10
years right eating that date
yep
okay i mean is there going to be a cut
off before that or how is that going to
continue this date one day
so it's it's an ongoing commission
that just has to do
reports um it doesn't it doesn't have
any funding oh and one thing i do want
to point out is that in the
the this version it i did take out the
state demographer and so there is no
state expenditure for this
um the departments have been able to
create the 10-year current service plans
themselves that was the concern of
theirs that they wouldn't know how to do
that without a state demographer to do
that for them thank you yeah yeah is uh
senator french on board with this
because he's awful quiet i'm just
checking i prefer to be quiet about
things i really don't know about
thank you all right uh you know some i'm
glad that uh i did call the committee
conference on this because we were
confused on it but uh erin you
definitely clarified it uh forrest there
and i i support it i'm
great do we have any issues here
okay then um i'm going to close
unless you have anything else to add to
it
you're good okay for the state reps if
you've never said you're going to have
to go down
uh to the
legislative research legislative office
here
and sign off on this here that we
support hb1106
and then i'll write a little statement
for the house
that in accordance with hb2 it was
mistakenly taken out that we're
support putting it back
okay now close the committee of
conference
thank you senators thank you
yeah
the next one my other one at one o'clock
we are
we're trying to see if we can find
senator d'alessandro but i'll give
little known and infrequently seen
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna call this
committee a conference on
house bill 1221 to order
and let me just start by saying i did a
little research on this i i think we all
agree to the underlying bill which is
reducing the business profits tax
from uh
from 7.6 to 7.5 percent
uh
and then i it looks like the genesis of
the amendment was senate bill 333
which uh
was pretty much innocuous bill wasn't
very complicated bill but on the on our
on our side at the house there was a
floor amendment
that added the
7.5 percent uh paid to uh
division one in division two
out of state money
but going forward forever
and
again most republicans
on our side
did not like this idea but there were a
few that voted for this
one up in the senate and my research
says that the 333 was
was
non-concur
fine
and i'm gonna i'm gonna look at senator
bradley maybe you can pick up the story
from that point uh what happened that
you attached this to
uh
a version of this to
uh thank you mr chair um
so
i mean this started out as
trying to get a temporary reduction to
the gas tax which
um as my colleague to my left will
attest and get too far too fast
and so
i thought that um
the whole purpose of
trying to reduce the gas tax was to help
people that are struggling right now and
it seemed like
the 7.5 on a one-year
one-time basis while we had the
surpluses we were generating was the
next best alternative so that was the
senate position
um
there's been a lot of debate and now i'm
just speaking for myself
on you know 7.5 percent permanently
i set it on the senate floor i'll say it
here again if we're generating
you know the kind of revenue that we are
right now i think you know we should do
it but that should be part of next
year's budget so what 1221 is is a
reduction of the bpt
and a one-time 7.5
payment to cities and towns for
retirement costs that will help property
taxpayers and it's accelerated to this
fiscal year 23. right
so the only question i have is
how do we know that the cities and towns
are actually going to put it to tax
reduction are we just faith or
i we don't know i think that center
guide added language to it that you know
makes it clear that that's what the
intent is
um
but
it's like anything else when we send
money back to
um cities and towns
you know it's local control
run by select boards city councils
um
so i guess i could
expand more upon that but i think i
don't need to that's fine yeah
representative lange
thank you i agree with senator bradley i
think that this is the best use that we
can possibly we have no control of what
the cities and towns we've made it clear
it's one time monies we obviously don't
want them to use this for ongoing
operational expenses but use for
one-time projects that they can they
won't have to spend money on in the
future
and i think the bpt is again that was a
good compromise by the ways and means
committee the house ways and means
committee from the original bill which
included bet
um i i think that again
the smartest move is one-time monies for
one-time projects and using our surplus
we have now to pay for this in this
current year makes absolute sense
okay
so
i don't have a problem with it either
uh the reason i we called a committee a
conference is that i had a i had a i
mean where ways and means this is a ways
and means bill
uh i went to
i'll be a legitimate assistant asked
okay what kind of money are we talking
about because it wasn't in the belt he
said around 28 million ish
so i said fine uh i went to my
leadership because okay is it on your
grand plan to spend 28 million on this
and
i finally got that answer
uh but in between we call a committee a
conference so
uh so
i i got clearance to
yeah the 28 million is in the plan if
you will of all the surplus spending
we're going to do
now some of my colleagues
are
well just like most of the of
people in our in my party uh did not
like the idea of this
the larger number going on forever and
ever
you two gentlemen have anything you want
to add uh but i think we're gonna i
think we're gonna concur with this uh
we're gonna
thank you mr chair i i think our
original
disappointment was that when we looked
at the amount 28 million it just so
happened that's roughly the amount this
bill 1221 started off as a reduction in
the business profits tax and the
business enterprise tax and
because there was some concern about um
the number of tax reductions we've done
you know and covet and everything else
you know where's this whole thing going
to come out
we put in an amendment and only reduce
the business profits tax and now with
this attached to it suddenly
there's the 28 million again but i
certainly understand the idea of trying
to in this time of difficulty helping
cities and towns um
with their tax
um you know reducing taxes so at this
point i
i would agree with it
you okay yeah
okay uh yes
just as a commentary
uh another thought in the in the process
was that we are in an extremely volatile
world and national economy with
inflation
nominally at eight actually around
seventeen percent
uh and so
rather than make it seven point five
percent contribution permanent
it would be better for the next budget
cycle when we sit down and determine
what the real inns and audi's actually
are based on then existing conditions
that would be much more appropriate to
make a decision such as this to make it
permanent after we have a little bit
more history on where the economy is
going and obviously the impact at four
dollars and forty cents a gallon for
regular at the pump this morning
uh that's not going to be good so again
i think caution is is appropriate i
think that one year
is a good deal representative lang thank
you thank you and again i i think it's
important to remember uh representative
that
the bpt is an ongoing permanent
reduction
whereas the 28 million again because we
were concerned about what was going on
is just a one-time expenditure and
that's why i supported the problem with
the bet is a long term and i think
senator guy is 100 correct that the
volatility of what's going on in our
economy we talked about the amount of
fake money in our state you know right
now with all the various
acts that the federal government's done
and dumped trillions of dollars out to
the market
we don't know how that's going to play
out long term so i think this is a
really smart move to use those one-time
monies
to that we have currently i think my
email this morning said we had 287
million in in current uh uh surplus so
it makes sense to use that million that
money to give whatever we can to the
towns to help them off on a one-time
basis
okay
uh
i'll just uh
make a motion that we would
i don't know what the motion would be
out that we would deceit i don't even
know if he needed emotions
yes
wang we're going to see
second janae again so we're willing to a
seed on our side
and i i would imagine you would have
concur with that ex session
okay well we're going to uh
come out of recess on house bill 355
and
i've since
since the senate called to recess i will
look into representative senator goddard
and
tell me anything new from your side
thank you mr noah the senate
would still
hold its position with respect to the
displays and i'll say that the house
still holds this position
so
um
it sounds like we're an impasse
to me
the house is already compromised as i
said yesterday
this bill came to us and the
prime sponsor is sitting here
we didn't we didn't act on it the first
year we retained it
and then we came up with a compromise
within our our committee
which was
the which is the bill that uh us to for
uh um a committee a conference on
was we
no we asked for the community conference
because right
you had amended the bill
i don't know um
i mean i i can just react to some of the
mine is a principle stance
it isn't like the senators didn't have
principal stances you have principal
stances too
i got one that comes to mind is
marijuana recent marijuana bill
was very principal stance against
uh and i
i you know i testified but then i
watched the end of that that hearing
back in the office
and
there were many there were many
businesses that wanted this bill to pass
you know even though
it was
the state ran the retail
but but everything else was private
sector agriculture you know growing
transport testing
and manufacturing
and i know when i chaired the marijuana
commission
years ago
the agriculture guys were there all the
time
wanting to say please
pass this because this means it means
something good for us to have another
but
to me
i mean i was against the bill too
the marijuana bill that we just
sent killed
but that was principal stance
and to me this is a principle stance and
that and i'm also
as chair i'm also of this group i'm also
representing the full
uh
house ways and means position
this our senate message came on this
bill early so we had a chance to talk
about this in ways and means
and the position was no let's hold our
position so i'm not it's not just the
the four of us here
um
it's
well it's five tim's not on
tim's just sitting here
so uh
and
our our guidance was hold
and they knew what the alternative was
is if
the
of the senate didn't exceed to our
position we'd just walk away
so
uh so that's where we're at if if you
don't see it if you uh
if you if you if you don't want to see
our position then we both walk away and
the bill dies
come back next year
um
when it comes to
the only other thing that was said
yesterday that was uh
you know
yes i know
i know
communities vote opt in to keno
but a lot of those communities voted in
it was remember was kino garden remember
we sold it as kindergarten we were going
to pay for kindergarten with this
i don't know if that was a factor in
towns voting for it
but it was also sold as just in
establishing stepper liquor
so and here now we're going to amend it
to be more inclusive of every other
business that has
has a license a a lottery license
you know the biggest ones being the
grocery stores and the convenience
stores but also the drug stores most
drug stores have them
and i i
personally
don't like that look but
but again those communities didn't
really
vote for that that have already voted so
we're not saying in this bill you have
to revoke
if you don't want it in your your local
uh
cvs or you know walmart or whatever
so
so that's that's
and i i think members of
the voting members here in the house are
pretty unified in that position so i'll
i would um
ask the chairman upon what principal
you base the decision to deny a business
owner
the right to display anything
in his or her business
i've offered the option of one display
limiting the size of the displays
to me the principle is
we support businesses here
this does no harm
and i would ask upon what principle you
feel you should deny
the screen in the store well i i just
got done explaining
so
you voted against marijuana bill what
principle did you use to deny the
growers
access to growing marijuana i mean it's
the same thing we the numbers of the
marijuana bill are astounding when you
offer a person to grow three plants not
that that's a topic of this discussion
the amount that they can produce far
exceeds
what they can use
therefore creating an opportunity for
sales and and adding to the black market
there isn't a child advocacy agency in
the country that supports the
legalization of marijuana under any
premise that's the principle that i use
protection of the society right that's
one of our obligations i don't see how
denying a screen protects society i do
see how it offends the right of a
business owner
to in fact engage in all of her conduct
of business well you know we talked
about yesterday we talked about
look i respect you guys just don't know
this is a friendly con little argument
so
i mean they're
someone said
well they can go to another store if
they don't like it
but again some of our smaller
communities their the next grocery store
is 30 miles away
so
if it's in the store then you're going
to say well they voted for this in the
town
but not everybody voted for it and i
just think most people don't want to
walk into their grocery store and see
these screens there
as if it's a little mini casino
they they don't want that and that's my
belief
so that's my so it's my principle
but that's also the belief of my full
committee
we we would have passed this bill
you amended what we we didn't want we we
did not want that
we amended the bill to we said okay we
heard the grocers we heard the
the convenience store guys they were
very vocal about this
that they cashing tickets from
restaurants that people leave early they
want to get the cash we're not getting
anything for it so we heard that so the
compromise was okay
it's just like any other lottery product
you can do it and you put a little
sticker on the window a lot of lottery
tickets sold here
but not the screens the screens are are
just it's a whole different look and
feel
can i may mr chair i have not received a
single email letter or phone call
opposing screens in a grocery store not
one i've received numbers of all three
supporting
the fact that they would like kino
i think as a display of the business
enterprise of kino i think it's really
it's it's
right it's it's not offensive
again i think that there's a way to get
a compromise which is what we'd like to
see
to
put one screen in
limit the size of the screens
but
say no screen and say that that's based
on principle
uh i don't i don't agree i think the
principle that we operate under in un
under live free or die here right it's
not it's not harmful if it's
objectionable that's a whole different
game
but it's not possible it was
injectionable to be adjustable to a lot
of people
how many letters did you get
i got none
most people don't even know what's going
on in the state house they have no idea
and i know there's a couple of couple of
locations
for conversations with
with the lottery
that would like to see this couple
couple
did not the entire grocer's association
come out in support yeah it's eight
percent
why one day it's it's it's money it's
it's
no i heard differently that a lot of the
big chains would not want this then they
don't have to take it i know they don't
have to take it
so
look
yeah sponsor can i speak
yes you could remember you made the
thank you mr chair so again i i think we
i don't think we want to get back into i
think everybody agreed that in general
the bill was a good idea that we want to
allow businesses the option
to retail that a licensed lottery
location is the option to sell keno in
places that have already approved
keynote i don't think that's up for our
discussion the only real issue that
we're that's the dividing line is
the screens
is whether or not we allow one screen no
screens or or an option for whatever
they want to do
and i guess i i bring it back is that
like the senators and even like yourself
as you just admitted
i got zero emails in opposition to this
bill and i advocated for this bill all
across my facebook and all across social
media because it was my bill as the
prime sponsor i got zero pushback from
citizens about the bill and
understanding what the bill was
um and i recognized i made the motion
and i recognize i'm a believer in
incrementalism i'll take something over
nothing if my only option is nothing and
in the committee my option was nothing
if i pushed it too hard against the may
i do think that there were members that
were in favor
of passing it with the may and not
requiring the business shall not but
allowing the business to make the
decision
um of the of of their choice and again i
think it's a reasonable compromise
especially from what i've heard where
they made a compromise if the concern we
heard was that you there was concern
about a keynote barn and people throwing
up a thousand screens and running keno
and grocery as a secondary option um and
i think it's a reasonable compromise if
we were to reach a one screen limit um
and and say that there it's your your
argument of having a kino barn goes away
um and it's a it's a reasonable
compromise giving the business a choice
if they want to put up one screen in
their seating area or wherever they want
then then that business can make that
choice i think that's a reasonable
compromise but the full ways and means
committee did not agree to that
and it's more than me talking here i'm
representing the committee
we're all representing the committee
if you like that idea bring it back next
year we'll see how a one screen bill
goes i'm not gonna i'm not i'm not i'm
not gonna uh
proceed yes it's caring
thank you mr chair
um not to get too far off track and i
appreciate your your position on
principle but you know in regard to the
marijuana bill
uh
the drug is illegal federally
and
it is our obligation to uphold our
constitutional rights
of our constituents the the reality of
the fact is that you get the right
administration in washington and a
directive comes down for the ag
to enforce the law
then everyone who has used marijuana
recreational
medicinal
or otherwise can be charged with a
felony and disarmed
by the federal government
that is my position and that's why i
have never voted
for that you want to get the federal
government to to devolve that back to
the states
we can have an honest discussion
about
whether whether marijuana should be
a product here in the states but as long
as you've got that conflict and we we
took an oath
basically to not not pass laws that are
conflicting with the federal government
and as long as uh that happens then
there's no way that i can change my
position
on that
now i
on 355 you know i've
been thinking since we we met yesterday
as to you know how we might be able to
do this but
what keeps coming back to me is that we
worked really hard last year
to come up with a budget that was going
to be
an economic engine
to new hampshire we did that by by
lowering taxes
uh by inviting businesses to come and
you know i am aware of
of large businesses that are planning on
coming to new hampshire i don't know
where they're going to get their workers
but but that's you know
that might be a challenge
for me on okay how do i draw them from
other states or but the fact is they
they made a decision
they're going to come to new hampshire
and they're going to establish
the business here
it is our job as legislators to create
the opportunity
for somebody to establish a business to
um once they do that it the risk is all
theirs
that that business may fail
i mean i'm i'm a selectman in the town
of milford i remember a time when
there was a tattoo uh piler that wanted
to come in
and
you know the boardroom was filled with
people and said
no we we can't we shouldn't have a
tattoo parlor
in town because it's not in a family
friendly you know in a family-friendly
environment
so i'm saying okay so like the
family-friendly environment like the bar
at this place and the bar at this place
and there's like four bars
around the oval in the center of town
now in the end that person had a good
record
from where they were coming there was no
reason why you shouldn't let them in
they came in they took the risk
a half a year later it didn't work out
for them
and they left
but that was totally their decision you
know we gave them the opportunity
to come in to establish their business
and and to try to grow it into something
successful so they can support
themselves and their family and i think
that's what we're trying to do
with this bill here is to create an
opportunity
and
i can't i can't
base
my opinion on whether just like the
tattoo parlor i'm it was someplace that
i would never visit
i probably wouldn't even promote it
but if other place other people wanted
to go there and and
do do whatever then that that was their
business
just just as if there's something in a
store
uh
if somebody doesn't want to look at a
screen
they can let the manager know
and again you know what drives business
up and up and down is whether
uh
the policies
of the management
are going to be
acceptable to the customers that walk
through the door
and if a business establishes something
and they start losing customers
chances are they're going to change it
and
you know i
you know i really hope that we could
really look back at at our position that
our position is to create opportunities
for business
and what we should be regulating is the
discriminatory actions
that that they might have against their
employees in terms of race sex
whatever um but but not not that we
shouldn't be regulating the aesthetics
of it well gary
senator guy uh
senator daniels
first off if we don't pass this bill
now one of the businesses we're talking
about is going to close not one not one
this is going to be such an
infinitesimal
amount of additional revenue
it's not going to make a matter it does
again and all the big players aren't
going to go for this anyway
so i
i
i you know and and keno alone isn't
going to bring any business in
it's not going to bring anybody who's
going to come and just have keynote but
we're trying to avoid that actually
uh so
and
and as we said yesterday there was some
concern about lottery revenues
but
you know we're going to be just fine
with the lottery because of the because
of the uh the gasoline prices and less
people buying scratch tickets at the gas
station
but on the other hand because i chatted
with the executive director after the
meeting that on the other hand our
sports betting is doing great guns
uh
not showing any slow down so we're way
ahead of budget
and yeah if if the gas prices continue
the way they are
yeah we will probably come back to more
normal range but but it's going to be
made up by
by
by the uh
the sports betting revenues
so i hear all of you um
just just call me a thick italian
mediterranean head here i knew you knew
would laugh at that
but uh but uh we're gonna hold our
guys
and a gaida
thank you mr chairman
um
in the interest of preserving the bill
the senate will accede to the house
position
with the commentary that that you've yet
to provide a principle upon which the
decision to refuse a store owner to to
show a screen in his or her store
and but we will exceed to the house
position and we will revisit it come
next year
thank you
thank you i think we are all set then
i'm going to open up the hearing on the
committee conference on
related to the positions within the
department of military affairs and
veterans services
and one of the things i'm not happy as a
chairman that two amendments were
attached
uh using veterans and i know it's not
you three right here it came from the
finance you know because some every two
years we'll use those political pawns
our veterans bills
you know they stick on amendments but
that's life
uh but anyways um i'd like to get some
on the first amendment
uh from the senate if you can ex
somebody can explain that when on the
medicaid
uh costs
the ambulances the ambulance medicaid
costs i'd be uh happy to um chair
balducero so in it's been let's say 17
years since we have actually
seen an increase a reasonable increase
in medicaid reimbursement rates for
ambulance services and why we're asking
for this
now is that
we have a not only a work we have a
workforce crisis and ambulance services
are having difficulty not only you know
staffing but with their operational
costs without an edge this is one way
that we can assist them in you know
meeting you know basically continuing to
operate and serving our communities so
it's as as i said it's been a long time
and i was approached
at you know
close to the 11th hour
about making trying to get something
done this year we have established a
workforce
study not a study community we've we've
started a workforce committee with
commissioner quinn over at the
department of safety and we're really
working hard on recruitment retention
issues and this was identified as a key
piece because we have limited sources of
fine of funding for emergency medical
service units so
we decided to try to raise these rates
because it hasn't happened in so long um
this will
especially in areas where there are
there's a high medicaid payer mix this
will make a significant difference so
it's a step in the right direction and
that's that's where this started
representative
yeah thank you mr chair um
would you please ask mr ribson to come
up
i think some of these questions may be
for him lipman sorry
i've got sununu on the mind
and who was
see i don't work with him that's why i
don't know
so mr littman has worked with us on this
he's the director of medicaid okay now i
know thank you welcome good afternoon
thank you um henry lipman the medicaid
director for the record
um in addition to what the senator
apprentice has outlined is
the commissioners received a number of
letters
emails from nursing homes that where
ambulance companies
based on the staffing crisis are not
um able to service the nursing
facilities which is resulting in delays
and some transfers um
and the concern is that
that is likely to get worse before it
gets better and
um while this won't solve the problem
completely it will i think contribute to
to a start to um and would appreciate uh
i think the
the issue of things starting to
unwind if you will for being able to
provide services something that's a
fairly recent phenomena it wasn't
necessarily present um a number of
months back but we're starting to see
some of you may have the
nursing homes that are affiliated with
the genesis in your communities and i
think
they're the largest provider and they've
two of the large ambulance companies
that service them have pulled out from
providing regular transfers
and that's i think why it's important to
try to do something in this session if
we could thank you
follow
uh so mr lipman i i have maybe four
really in the
scenario
um
it was stated that there hasn't been an
increase in medicaid reimbursement rates
for ambulance services for 17 years is
that true
the um two 3.1 percent increases did
did
improve the rates of ambulances but i
can share with you that there's
compared to medicare for example their
weight loss
i want to just stay on yes
what rates we had and when we had them
so i i heard that we haven't had one in
17 years you're saying we've had a
couple in the 17 years could you just
tell us the year and the amount
in 20 and 21 january 20 and 21 there
were two 3.1
increases that were covered in the
overall provider rate increase is my
recollection
okay okay
so follow go follow let him finish it um
okay so so those raises i assume went
through the governor's standard uh
budget process
and the governor determined uh that
process determined that 3.1 percent was
the right amount is is that correct
no that wasn't across the board it
provided to all um providers of of
services
it was across the board that was in hb1
hb 2 in
2019 i think session to be implemented
okay so the governor didn't put it into
the budget it came in the back end
during hb2 we real apparently somebody
realized the rates were too low and a
senator or a representative
put the 3.1 percent in
i'm just i'm trying to understand the
chronology of who did what and how
much there hadn't been a rate increase
for 17 years
until
the legislature in 2019
session
approved a 3.1 percent increase for all
providers in medicaid
service providers in medicaid
to be implemented on january 1 of 20 and
january 1 of 21 so there was nothing
distinct for ambulance services it was
across the board to all providers
follow-up
okay so what i think you just told me is
why i don't recall this in division
three that this was not part of the
governor's budget proposal increasing
the rates for
ambulance services specifically
because i'm trying to remember why i
don't remember this because i think it
was in the session before you were yeah
it was 19 sessions yeah yeah
it was implemented in 20 and 21 but not
we had no clue on it we liked it i agree
probably but we don't know so that's why
we're glad you're here and well thank
you as the chair of division three uh
finance i i it's this is just sort of a
common area feel free to keep going all
right thank you sir um
okay so
this couldn't have been a crisis
only in the last couple of years we we
why do you think
there wasn't a raise proposed in the
normal order of business in the
governor's
budget
so i think
coming out of the pandemic right or in
the pandemic period
a number of
the
emt ems people
migrated to other parts of the health
care system whether it's working in
hospital er departments um working in
urgent cares doing other types of things
i think
we had a meeting with the head of ems in
terms of licensure in in the state
that even though the workforce is not
changed a lot it's not changed a lot the
line a lot of uh ambulance ems providers
leaving if you will the ambulances fire
services
and it's really again only um
since probably march april time frame
that we
are starting to really see
where ambulance companies are
withdrawing from providing chair car
services from ambulance services to to
nursing facilities and and if this is
being seen in other states as well you
know massachusetts has had the problem
we were we had seen it after the budget
was long
pie us to start to see the problem
actually materializing in our region and
uh uh thank you again uh mr chair all
right so
um
in the upcoming governor's budget
process
is there going to be a specific request
for ambulance services increases
i think that we would need to consider
doing more than what's what's here if
the
the trends continue to go the way
they're going um i think we're in a
beginning crisis phase i think
oh
i turned that off i i really did
my smartphone has outsmarted me again
yeah i i think that we will need to do
more than here but i think it's
important to do something now i mean
what's proposed here amounts to a
increase in the current medicaid
fee schedule for ambulances but we're
still well below even half of medicare
i can't imagine anything being half of
medicare um that's that's why we're
having the problem so so in closing mr
chair i i would say
that division iii fully funded every one
of the governor's direct care budget
line items this past
budget cycle and had this been put in
the budget it would have been funded and
so now we're showing up it's a crisis i
don't like crisis so if we could just
figure out why we failed to plan
because that turns out to be a plan for
failure so if we could figure out how to
do it right in the next budget cycle and
continue to do it right i i would
appreciate that
well certainly we'll we'll do a a better
job i think what was not apparent to us
is
what would happen in the period of
during 20 and 21 let's say in terms of
what's happened to the health care labor
market and you know we the department
prepared its budget
you know at a time when it looked like
all this was over and and certainly um
it's over in many respects but in terms
of the healthcare workforce it's not
um so so so yes sir i will admit that
your pro your your job is a lot harder
than mine because it's just a lot easier
to throw dirt clods from here but but i
i i if we are less and i'm
be able to do this the right way in the
future so that our health care system
can plan and stabilize and and take care
of our citizens
you you probably recall if i could add
just my comments if that's okay mr
chairman um just that
when we began um looking at financial
items at one point it looked like the
state was gonna be like a 300 million
dollar 500 million dollar deficit so in
terms of trying to put more money
in the in the budget you know that
what was not known was how much federal
money was going to come in thereafter
that being said i take your comments to
heart and
we will try to do a better job in the
upcoming budget
okay before i go to senate parents mass
miller and then senator hennessey
one question that pops in my mind
868 0264
does this keep make us compatible with
like other states or are we still below
the totem pole here i think we're we're
well below the the totem pole for you
know ambulance ambulances unfortunately
have not
received a lot of attention over the
over
better than a decade um
you know just to give you um we had done
some calculations to to bring us up to
50 of medicare would have been um
a 2.3 million dollar number to bring us
um
up to uh
the
the average rate for the new england
states would have been a four million
dollar number just to give you some
perspective on he might be answering the
question okay thank you uh senator
apprentice
thank you thank you chairman balducero
and
a lot of
representative edwards questions in
terms of the chronology covered some of
the points that i was i was going to
help but director lipman has handled
that for me um i did
if i may take this moment to respond to
your last question about what's
happening around us in other states is
that appropriate or do you want to wait
no that's appropriate because i'm
wondering i don't know if we have the
power to if i had the power i'd raise it
i mean i don't know if i do it but you
know i mean if we're sticking it to our
ambulance drivers
then we should be taking care of them
right do it think
but
thank you and uh so maine reimburses
at base rates of a hundred percent of
medicare vermont
reimburses and this is
at base rates at 74 of medicare
connecticut reimburses at 72
massachusetts at 62 percent
and just if i may director lipman and we
are at i'm
we're we're the lowest we're we're the
lowest yeah 38 percent
we're still below 50 to get it up to 50
would require
both state and federal funds of 2.3
million
this proposal at 15 percent
uh at 887 000 which is in here is
000 is the state share
the federal share is five almost 545.
i think that as i understood from
leadership standpoint that
as you had suggested we need to do more
work in this area and i think
in part i think this is a step to get to
the next step
uh representative hennessey i mean i'm
sorry senator anderson thank you um
question for um director lipman then so
my understanding when i was on senate
finance when we added these funds that
these funds 868
which i believe are all general funds
right 868 000 no the the the number
there is there's a state share in a
federal share so is it 50 50. it's a
little bit better than 50 50. it's uh
probably closer to
56 or 58 federal
so my understanding then that would
bring us from 38 to 50 is that not
correct um
that's not correct to get us to 50 the
calculation was
um
it would take 927 000 in
in general funds and almost a million
for in federal funds to get us to 50 of
medicare
so what is what is what does uh 868 and
combined funds get us now
um
i don't have that calculated off the top
of my head i i do know that what it
amounts to is 15 percent over what we're
paying today which probably is probably
pretty close to the
30 mid to upper 30s that you had
suggested
but you
i know senator sharon carson told me
they taught me years ago make sure you
take care of our employees so
i got to make sure i don't screw up on
director
okay wait a minute i'm still are you
done santa hennessy
yeah i'm just confused i thought we
brought the rates up to from 38 to 50.
do we have the power to do that on uh
in a uh committee conference i'm if i'm
sorry
if the 868 is a um
is the general fund portion then yes you
i thought the 868 was a total
appropriation
i have to shout mr chairman if i may if
you get the side by side
it does say under section 8 on the last
on page 7
that
the department of health and human
services shall increase the medicaid
reimbursement rate for ambulance
services to be equal to 50
of the medicare rate i didn't see that
language i apologize so that's 868 would
be correct to bring it up this funding
will bring it up and i think
um and also regards to representative
edwards comments that
um this will he will bring this forward
during the next budget cycle and this is
something that we do need to continue to
work on
so i i think that um this is in my
opinion anyway it's entirely appropriate
we do need
at least 50 percent we can't um add that
to uh
for folks for out-of-pocket expenses
it's extremely expensive and the more
money that
the state can pay
to help people so they're not struggling
with out-of-pocket medical expenses i
think is entirely appropriate
okay thank you representative
oh i'm sorry representative
um
is this an
ongoing issue that will have to be
addressed annually or will that 50
stay across the board for an uncertain
amount of time i think that is sort of a
point in time measurement um
you know typically medicare is going up
in the low single digits uh you know you
see typical rate increases two or three
percent
um
sometimes a little bit more than three
percent but you don't typically see
medicare going up
from a provider standpoint in jumps of
like
thank you okay uh rather than beat this
anymore to get a consensus here we uh we
one more go ahead uh thank you mr chair
so i assume that the that this is still
under the f map percentages and we're
getting a little bit more federal money
for our dollar these days yes and then
uh given that's the case
if we were to increase the general funds
portion of this
are we confident that the feds would
have the money to continue the fmap
match
yes
okay so if we threw another hundred
thousand and the feds would come back
with another 120 or whatever the math is
yes
all right
so so based on that uh if we could have
a discussion i i i'd be open to
increasing the amount a little bit but
that's just me what's the uh census here
on increasing
i think the senate would be very happy
if the house agreed with
the eight hundred and six
sixty 68 000 of general funds that we've
allocated to increase the rates and that
to look at it again next year no more
um
i just don't know where we're at right
now money-wise so
well i know i met with the speaker
earlier he was talking about uh revenue
project uh 400 million
uh but i i kind of agree with you i want
to raise it but
i'm not a finance person and i think
we have maybe six months left to go to
the next budget cycle so i would think
here this would cover us
until then and then the new budget to go
ahead like you said
and go at it i kind of agree with you
there
anyone else yes chairman balducero and
members of this this the plan
was to
make this increase now
and to
start working immediately on what we
should be doing for more sustainable
pathway and coming back and working on
the but putting this into the budget
next year so that is we're making this
ask now knowing that we have more work
to do
and so i just wanted to share that okay
anyone else
so do you want to make a motion i mean
uh no no i'm still in the discussion
mode if that's okay i i the the the
reason i'd be open to increasing it some
is because we're
under the f map matching
and that that f map matching is going to
go away at some point and
i i just assume if it were there for a
little while to take maximal advantage
of it uh
our money's worth more under fmap than
it will be when fmap goes away so it
just seems like it might be timely could
you could you tell us mr littman when
fmap is projected to go away the extra
matching
so um i think that we'll have it at
least till the quarter ending september
um and then
potentially uh based on the news
yesterday that there's
expectation it may be extended one more
time it could be to the
end of this uh calendar year i think for
certain you could count on through
september um and potentially until the
okay so
i'm okay with the senate position i just
i'm okay with making hay while the
sunshine
yes we would appreciate you
okay then uh i'm gonna put this aside we
all in census we agree with this here
amendment okay then we're done with that
one uh let's move on to the next one
please
um
let me see
let me get what i want here on the next
one here which on the million dollars
thank you mr chair could i invite
senator
lou d'alessandro up to the microphone
welcome to senator
thank you mr chairman uh for the record
i'm
senator lou d'alessandro i represent
district 20 manchester awards three four
thank you senator um i know that you and
senator guida worked on this amendment
and i know you have a lot more history
on on this so could you tell us the
importance of the million dollars sure
some of us were around
when arby came to us
and presented a proposal to the
legislature with regard to a a project
that they were developing in manchester
the united states department of defense
granted army an 80 billion dollar grant
to get into the regeneration process
where they would do
[Music]
uh practice let's call it exotic
medicine the creation of of organs
and the creation of organs
would play a very significant role in
how we treat our troops coming back
uh from
from a war to an area or something of
that nature and it was a part it's
really a parts replacement situation
and dean cayman
has been uh
well loaded throughout the world really
for some of his inventions he invented
the insulin pump he invented the
wheelchair he invented the the
wheelchair that climbed stairs
and
he uh invented the segway
but very very intense
research
in
very cutting edge
cutting-edge research and the creation
of organs the creation of body parts
i mean do you know what that would do uh
to the world that we live in today
the the lives that would be saved
so he uh came and came to the
legislature and i think most of the
house and senate approval
we gave
to to the army
a tax situation where we negated
their business profits and their
business enterprise tax for 10 years
in association with that
a fund the governor agreed to this a
fund was going to be set aside it would
be it would max out at five million
dollars
that money to be used to redeem loads
of people that were we were bringing in
to do this extensive research
because it does take
a credentialed individual to perform
this research
now the caveat was this
if a person got loan forgiveness
they would they would have to work five
years with the program
in order to get loan forgiveness
the the loans the money would be given
uh to uh
let's call it the
the old
research and development i'm trying to
think of the old name of the program but
it's now run by
uh state
the state they would manage the granting
of these loans
the loan forgiveness aspect and make
sure that everything was was cut and
drive the governor was uh very uh very
up for doing this
and it was a five five billion would be
set aside over a period of time
and
uh that that was going to be a general
fund of appropriation that's how all of
this started and that was the genesis i
think of of the the five uh the the one
million that they came to the uh to the
senate and asked for and i think uh
senator geider was the the person who
sponsored that piece of piece of
legislation
now
in looking this is this is in essence
part of workforce development to be
honest with you
but you you needed this
uh from their standpoint you needed this
this item
this loan forgiveness aspect of it to
draw in these very highly qualified
individuals who would be performing the
research
now i've visited arby and i i encourage
every one of you to visit
uh dean cayman's decca
outfit in manchester an army is in
an old and older building that was at
one time owned by the university and
these research projects are taking place
and
the initial the initial research is
heart regeneration and it's amazing to
me some of the things that have gone on
and uh that that uh senator hennessy is
sort of the genesis of of the program
the idea of of the money and it was a
five million dollars was gonna was going
to be the number and the governor was
going to uh
uh appropriate that was going to come
out of the governor's fund and he was
going to ask the legislature to
appropriate that money it was a 5
million max it would be managed
by state aid by the state agency and
the caveat was they would remain in the
okay if if i may add here i could
probably clarify with just exactly what
you're saying here
i had lunch with senator bob geider uh
this morning i met with the speaker and
we pulled the law on this here my
understanding is and why i was against
this here as a chair when putting it on
a veterans bill was because there was no
hearing but apparently i was wrong told
wrong on that because my understanding
is the original bill for this here was
stuck in on a labor bill
went to labor
the speaker decided it was non-germane
it had a hearing
it was
kicked out of the house here because of
non-germaine
went back the senate put it on this here
now
the
in the bill it has rsa 162-t
colon 3.
what that meant to me in the speaker and
we pulled it because he really didn't
know either and we seen it july of 29th
of 2018 hearings were held on this
then it was put in the budget but
somewhere along the line somebody failed
to fund it
so it was in hb2 it wasn't uh except it
was not made it over to hb1 am i correct
yes okay so i this was out of the
meetings after the ranking member on the
democrats side uh we were both
discussing this earlier on why i had to
dig into a little bit more to see what i
was dealing with because i had no clue
so
i'm hoping that will clarify in some mis
some confusion that we had on this here
on why maybe
it needs to move forward because as the
speaker said
uh it's
give them a million bob geider said
let's see how it goes with that million
dollars
and then if it's not needed then we
won't need to send the rest of the money
but this is a
you know a test run to see how much
money they actually need for this
so this money goes to army what happens
if another regenerative manufacturing
group comes in are they able to tap into
the money or is this exclusively for
army
the program was set up specifically for
army but i think if a regenerative
manufacturing company came in
they could exercise or they could ask
for the same
the same uh
criteria that
was given to army but i think it would
have to be again you'd have to vote on
it here in the legislature because
zombie is the designated
army is the designated receiver right
now
okay the other question that i have
thank you senator the other question
that i have is why is it non-lapsing
it's non-lapsing because if you don't
they they continue to recruit and they
haven't spent it in one year you don't
want it to lap so you'd have to
reappropriate in the second year so
you'd retain it and you'd retain it over
over a period of a a period of time
you always want to keep recruiting
so is there a time cap on that of five
years or no uh
i don't i don't i don't think so the the
cap the cap was on the amount of money
that we would give we would give five
million dollars and they would have to
be remade in employment for five years
but they want to keep recruiting and so
if they couldn't get anybody in the
first year make it non-lapsing would be
attractive for the second year this is
an on this is an ongoing process
as far as recruitment is concerned
they're going to be recruiting for
quality people for a long period of time
yeah under uh the rsa that i mentioned
that's in the bill it basically goes
into explains a lot of this here but it
talks about bonding and other stuff i
don't know bonding means the money that
we're giving that will go to them
it was a it was a i i if it spawned
that was maybe a methodology that was
discussed but indeed a direct
appropriation
is a much better way to do this
and there's a there's another way to do
this that we're working on uh you know
in order to come up with the with the
money but i i think uh you could have
done a board but
i i don't think that was an appropriate
way to do it
if the a better alternative were
available
okay so
i think
because i need to keep it simple for me
uh
the house and the senate have already
agreed on the policy dating back to 2018
we had already agreed on a dollar amount
much larger than a million dollars right
and and so we're just
trying to resolve
uh sort of a legislative faux pas that
we didn't actually put the money where
our mouth was yeah exactly uh what we're
trying to do is fulfill a legislative
follow-up
okay so because because of that i i
think i can just support it but
uh i wanna i wanna talk about the
non-lapsing thing because i think that's
an interesting comment
um
i i um i see that it needs to be
non-lapsing because uh otherwise uh if
we did this now it would expire june
30th and that's just not enough time to
do anything
but it does make me wonder if since
since we really don't know what the
uptake rate is
if we should in order to keep from this
money getting
you know pigeonholed and lost
if we should put in
uh a lapse date of of 23 june 23
so that
the lapsing it gives us budget
discipline and and helps the accounting
system keep track of the money which
reduces fraud waste and abuse which is a
good thing
so so what what what are your comments
on
maybe we should say
non-lapsing until june 30 2023.
well good comments appreciate those i
think
because it's a recruitment situation
and and you know
you know that it takes a lot of time to
get the to get these individuals
you should give them a time period
maybe a couple of years and
haven't lapsed in a couple or three
years because they're constantly
recruiting for the best people for these
positions these these people are hard to
find
and it i think you talked about advanced
advanced studies people and so forth so
i i think the non-lapsing feature
and again they don't get the money that
money would be held by the state and
would be distributed once good
candidates come and the army comes in it
goes through the process i think
uh
what what's his what's the person's name
uh who would
the old industrial development authority
what's that called what's that the uh
are you talking about the military base
no no no no no the industrial
development authority used to handle
grants a lot like like this but now it's
it's uh kiwi what's his name
key wallace key wallace's key wallace's
entity would handle the money the money
would never go to army the money would
be retained by the state
army would would then make a
recommendation based on the employee
key wallace would then give give them
the money so that's that's that's why
the non-lapsing feature i think is a
good one because the money's always
retained by the state senator i'm going
to go with another follow-up in a second
but what you just said bob gotta told me
at lunch time that the way they found
out the money wasn't funded because
people went in for the grant and there
was no money they found out that it was
never funded so there was a mistake on
on our part the house and the senate
and that was coming from senator geider
but follow up
okay so i i just want to probe the
non-lapsing issue just another time and
that is and maybe mr williams could has
an answer to this because it's it's he's
got experience in this area
have we ever set things up so that it
would be non-lapsing at the end of the
next budget cycle like so for example if
if we bought into the idea that it's
going to take a while to get the
recruiting but at the same time we
wanted to safety guard it so that this
money isn't out there in perturbity
could could we set it up as non-lapsing
for june of 2025 which would be the
entire next budget cycle i think we do
with the veterans scholarship fund
the money we used to put in there kept
rolling over and over but go ahead do
you have an answer mr williams
um thank you very much uh and and uh
chairman thank you for this opportunity
for the record john williams the
director of legislative affairs for
health and services and i have worked on
the budget process and i was trying to
make some eye contact with former
representative aaron hennessey now in
the senate and she's also had experience
in this deferring to the the working
with the legislative budget assistance
office uh you can certainly push it out
to having the funds lapsing on a date
certain typically at the end of a state
fiscal year uh generally the state has
been very conservative to pushing it out
too far you hear about encumbering
future legislators but i've seen recent
examples of pushing it into the upcoming
biennium
thank you
so the short answer was yes we could go
to june 20 25. unfortunately the juris
doctored it and by name adds a few words
to it so but yes thank you
representative hennessey thank you i
mean senator hennessey i keep saying
that's okay
sorry
mr chairman can you tell me since you've
read that today does it say that a an
applicant would would have a five-year
payout because they have a five-year
commitment my concern is if we make this
fund lapse in two or three years that
somebody who has made the five-year
commitment
is going to get stuck with something and
this is similar to state loan repayment
program funds where we've made that fund
um non-lapsing i believe so that we
don't
get people stuck
i i know senator geider was taught the
way he was talking like a four or five
year program this is
uh that's involved and then every year
more and more kids uh students come
forward to sign up so the money has to
be ready available and if you go i would
think if you go after that five-year
process it's going to cause problems
uh i would think with students that are
stepping up until
you decide to fund it and they see how
the million dollars went
i i don't think you paid that
again this is this is a supposition
because the rules are in place
but i don't think you pay it all off at
once that you pay the loan off on an
incremental basis that's how you retain
it for the five years
and that's why the non-lapsing nature it
is so imperative because once the guy
signs up the middle the woman signs on
for five they want to be sure that
they're going to get there
get their their loan
rescinded
yeah
i mean it's truly it's truly uh from
their standpoint i think
it's a it's a workforce
recruitment
tool that they perceive that that they
need to get the kind of people that they
need to get into this
to this area of of business yeah it's a
very sophisticated business follow-up if
sure
uh thank you mr chair so
so the way i understand something like
this would work is if we put this
million dollars in now and we set it up
with the guard rails of expiring in in
essentially three years
we'll have gone through two full budget
cycles before the end of 25
and so if it requires more money in
order to make good on the five-year
commitments future legislature
legislators could put that money in
there
but this million dollars would be set up
to where there would be you know
accountability and control and
and
and hopefully since we thought it would
cost five million and this is only one
million it'll probably be spent by the
end of the end of the three years so i i
don't i don't know instinctively i i
think it may be a good idea to go ahead
and have the money lapse in at the end
of 25.
uh if i may uh go ahead before i go to
the ways and means wanted to speak up on
it that's why but go ahead senator yeah
so i just have a concern if we
give this million dollars and then make
it lap actually for years that it says
no forgiveness of such student
indebtedness shall be affected unless
the person shall have been employed to
perform primarily active regenerative
manufacturing business activities at a
location within new hampshire for a
minimum period of five years
so if somebody
comes to new hampshire because they know
they're going to get their student loans
prepaid and they make that five year
commitment
because they see we just put a million
dollars in here but then we take the
money back in three years
it doesn't work they're going to be
asking
but no one would have had gotten that
money
i gave my word the percent of the guider
i would stick with the uh the law the
way it's written because of what you
just said that's why we read the law on
the five-year window and i think if
anything if they're gonna do it maybe do
it at the five-year not three there may
be because we'll go against the rsa
that's in place there may be a chance
where someone's already started a work
commitment and so they could get money
sooner but um i think perhaps a
another option would be that
once a year someone has to go before
fiscal and report on the fund balance so
that we know
we we have
don't interrupt your center but we've
got in a bill that that we passed we ask
for an annual report
from the from the the uh from army to
both
ways and means of the house ways and
means of the senate finance of the house
and finance in the senate so they should
be reporting on an annual basis as to a
how the project's going it'd be how how
this this situation is going and also
key wallace would be
i think under the setup would be in
charge of this
more reason to make it not lapsing
representative brown you had something
to add
sorry i walked in the middle of this um
so yeah i guess you know the back story
on this i mean we passed the spell four
years ago
uh when we we did the um
senator goddard myself and
representative ames are on the tax
expenditure review committee
and we finally asked the army to come in
because we're wondering what that's
going on
so
key wallace was the first one to testify
about the tuition part of the bill
because there's the other the tax tax
break part of the bill
and that's when we discovered that
that we never funded i guess i asked him
i said
so you set up the rules you did all that
okay so how many people are taking
advantage of this he goes nobody i go
why not well the house i mean let's say
she never funded it
so representative senator guida said
i'll take care of it
so he originally filed a bill
i attached it to a labor bill
was the wrong place to go
it was ruled
it was ruled non-germane by the speaker
then they attached it to then they
attached i think your finance committee
attached it to
to this bill
so understand that yes we're four years
into 10 years 10 years at 10 years ends
all this money reverts it's no good per
what you were just reading senator
hennessey
i think that i think you're uncovering
something that we didn't really
anticipate but no money's gone out in
four years
there might be some money going out
in in the coming years
but the law of the law ends i mean it
just ends and we would assume any any
extra money that's sitting there would
just
not be allowed to be paid out
i think that's something we got to
clarify it sounds like um
whether or not you want to clarify it
here or not uh that's
you know well the window says five years
of uh students are there any stu no
students are in the pipeline right now
but i understand there were students
that tried and couldn't get involved
because there was no you said there was
no funding
so right there's no funding if you do
the three year like representative
edward saying doesn't that cause a
problem with somebody within a five year
window
yes because
they they work five years and that's how
you you redeem the note over the
five-year period
a portion of it
on an individual basis that's i assume
that's how the program was going to be
set up
and uh
again
the key
the key the key to keeping the
individual there is the five years the
redemption of the loan takes place over
a five-year period representative
okay so what i was uh obsessive
compulsive about is the notion of some
kind of a sunset date and a way to make
the money accountable what i think i
just heard representative abrami tell us
is that the law itself sunsets in six
more years and that we would probably
sweep any funds that were still in this
account so that takes care of my sunset
obsession and i'm i'm i'll stop talking
about it okay thank you
did you have anything else yet
no other than
we asked uh
we asked the uh from army the uh
associate director uh
miss uh tui
uh
about how important this is
and she says well we just added another
25 000 square feet
we're still bringing people and we're
still bringing companies in so she said
this is very important that we we do
have this to attract to attract these
phd types that they want
that's a win-win for new hampshire thank
you uh we anyone else had anything to
add before uh uh
i think we may be all set yeah i think
yes under the workforce development for
the uh the program that is called
yes um
okay are we all uh on board with this do
we have any problems with this
john i'm good
okay then i will go ahead and follow the
report that uh we support uh both
amendments from the senate i'm glad you
were able to break it down because i'ma
tell you i came in today thinking i was
killing this a veteran's bill to get rid
of this
uh but uh
i'm glad we were able i had to educate
myself earlier with the speaker he had
to educate himself on it and
you know
it worked out great okay so
i take it we're all set so i will file
the report and then hopefully this
evening or tomorrow you'll all be able
to sign off on the bill you can just
call in
and to ols and they'll sign you off did
you have something to add your
representative
oh i'm on my last hearing
and i didn't screw it up
yeah
yep this this is my last hearing 16
years reputation that we said yes to
each other yeah
yeah
that's a great picture all right okay
i'm going to close the committee uh
conference on uh hb 1256 and i will file
a report with the clerk and the
um ols thank you well for coming and
before we put it on this bill i called
representative allard the prime sponsor
to make sure he was okay with it he
thought it'd be a great bill to put it
on since army does so much for that
right for injured troops
so we
wouldn't put it on this bill unless the
prime sponsor wanted it on me okay
no that's fine
and i
when they put something on it like uh
something like me or my committee yeah
we have no clue yeah when it comes to
that's why we have just edward going
here on the nissan health side yeah that
was it was after crossover so we had to
use a house bill and i talked about that
we worked it out i educated myself with
wait
senator rebecca perkins quoca
senator bob gaida
thank you mr chairman
uh
gun stock has been
the focus of a very unfortunate set of
circumstances
uh in 1959 legislation was passed
designed to prevent political
interference
in the business operations of the
mountain very clear from the intended
legislation
it left a proviso in that law that
allows the delegation
to appoint the members of that
commission
and
the delegation acting within its lawful
authority
but with misfeasance that's a legal term
that means the inappropriate application
of law
okay
has replaced
most of that commission
with people who are
unqualified
in terms of professional background
people who have political agenda
again
in violation of the intent of that law
and
have caused significant distress amongst
the population of belmont county to it
two petitions with 3 600 signatures
opposing the direction that the
delegation is taking with its political
maneuvering
to try to achieve a political outcome
they have removed one person who was
eminently competent mr mcclear
who built church landing from a waste on
the edge of lake winnipesaukee into the
fantastic facility it is today
they have isolated the
former chair
to wit
they will not even entertain
agenda items that he is considering
because he is from the group that
developed this master plan what master
plan they spent almost five years
developing a master plan
and
uh that master plan
presents a phased approach to possible
improvements to gun stock to make sure
that it is both up to date and
sustainable for the long term
now
the harm done by
this
turnover
is that the team that they have
dismantled
produced a 9 million dollar
surplus
this year
when for the past 63 years that the
existing law was in place
it was marginally profitable they had to
borrow money from the county
okay and
and so what they've done is dismember
the paradigm that was successfully
making gun stock what it needs to be to
be sustainable for the foreseeable
future
the
people of belknap county
by the thousands have expressed their
support for this amendment
and given the consequences of the
actions of a delegation that is
hell-bent on not caring about the
electorate
this amendment has come forward and i
would ask you to vote in the affirmative
senator
all i would i would add that
this was passed on a voice vote through
the through the senate um
but i will also add
i mean i
probably should have just talked about
the the underlying bill which was um
passed
through your committee and that is also
high support in the senate for the
um
the
terms for some of the rockingham county
elections
i would state that it is germane in the
sense that we are talking about
elections
and terms of office
i would also state that there's serious
harm done
with the continuing passage of time as
more commissioners get elected this fall
and so forth there is harm done has
already been done to the institution of
gun stock
and so again i believe that because it's
a bill related to elections that it is
germaine it should be considered that
thank you mr chair with all due respect
um
this amendment
is is not germane
and in fact
because the chair of
election law and municipal affairs
determined it to be non-germane that
there was a hearing
because of its non-germaness so
i i don't um
i don't agree with that assertion that
while it may not be germaine it is
attached to the bill and it did pass the
senate so as far as we're concerned it
is um a part of the bill and i also was
requested mr chair if you could turn
thank you uh
i'd like to keep it quiet
uh
any other comments yes representative
thank you mr chair um
i completely support
the notion of having gunstock elected
when i started in
local government 22 years ago
the first i came on the heels of a
warrant article to change the zba in
northampton from an appointed
body to an elected body because of
everything that i'm hearing here that's
happening in gunstock and since then
the zba has moved along quietly
and with efficiency
and without the political turmoil that
comes with that can come with
appointments
i
when i first read this
i'm still new as a sophomore here i i
question my understanding of the word
germaine
uh as i've seen it with a few different
bills i think germain means the subject
matter needs to be to relate to one
another but i understand here it's a
little bit different we have a bill in
front of us with two parts to it
i support both parts of this bill
um if if
but i so
not being 100 sure of how we can get
both of these to pass i'm willing to do
whatever it takes to get both pieces of
these to pass because as i understand it
the gun stock piece would take place in
the 22
election which would be november
so if this were to pass and be signed in
june then we could have an effective
transition in november
um i just don't understand how that
would happen unless we can do it as one
piece right here but so uh i don't know
that i've offered a solution but i've
offered my opinion thank you
any other comments
yes
representative thank you mr chair i
would also like to add that um
because of the seriousness of the
content of this amendment
it makes substantial changes to
the 1959 law that's been working for 63
years
i'm not
comfortable with the process and the way
that this is
being brought about
it needs to be
filed as an lsr and it needs to go
through the process
and it needs to be heard in in the house
so
i think that's that's an important um
consideration
so let me let me ask before we get too
far down the road we're still going to
be shooting for three o'clock but if we
go over we'll go
uh is
is this is the position
of the senate
uh
pretty hard at this point or i do have
do you have much uh
willingness to have some leeway here
i think the senate position is very firm
and i would offer in rebuttal
that the system has not been working
given the marginal financial performance
for 63 years
when this when the
team that put a 9 million dollar surplus
in the bank
okay is being dismantled for political
reasons
that is not working
and gun stock according to 3 600
signatories on a petition for a county
unheard of i've never in in 30 years in
politics
seen a county issue raised such a level
over 300 articles in the paper
okay numerous letters to the editor
scurrilous scandalous remarks about
myself
my sonal agenda here is putting the
future of gun stock
okay a time critical decision has to be
made we can't wait two more years okay
putting the future of gun stock in the
hands of its owners
letting the public vote on the people
they want to run their mountain
if we deny that we say they're not
competent that's what we're saying here
and i disagree with that notion thank
you mr chair thank you senator uh i
think at this point
yes senator
can we recess for about five minutes yes
that was going to be my next comment was
that i think we probably need to
caucus if you will if that's the right
term the senate
uh members
uh about five minutes talk about your
position and the the house will do the
same and will reconvene at three
right
where we have another
committee of conference that was
supposed to start at three so we're
going to move through this quickly if it
looks like we're we're not going to
be able to get through this rather
rapidly
i'll suspend our discussion and we'll
yes ma'am i i have another one that's
suspended to 3 30 and then 3 45 can we
do four
sure
um
our the house position at this point our
position
is that
we're not going to allow this bill to
move forward unless the senate proceeds
and the senate's position is they both
okay and so we're at a
might i suggest a recess
well
we could do that but we won't get back
together until four
all right well if we have time now it's
what well you have a level you have
another
committee of conference supposed to
start at three so we'll do that to 3 30
and then we'll be available too that's
fine
you're i think senator bird says europe
sounds like your schedule is going to
drive this
um
i'm good for recessing until four
okay
thank you
okay we'll uh
we'll end this
uh discussion and and retake it back up
at uh approximately four
o'clock
this is typical this is what is going on
this one's for you you can read as you
hey
yeah i'm just getting my junk out of the
yeah i think there's an amendment from
we're now gonna uh convene the committee
of conference on house bill 1293 and i
would ask that the senators
uh introduce yourselves
still senator gaiden
senator bill cannon from sandown which
is the wine district of new hampshire
and we have
on on the repub on the uh
on the house majority side we have
representative power representative
piamonte representative dolan and
representative majori
so welcome and uh
uh
with one of the one of the senators like
to take the lead and explain sure your
position thank you
um and and uh thank you representative
for creating a bill that we love so much
that we added things to it
um but i will say you know we appreciate
it very much the um bill coming over
from the house i think a very necessary
change and uh
as you know des
thought that this would be an
opportunity to clear up some things that
needed to be cleared up for a number of
years and be a good vehicle uh for that
and then thirdly um there was the
opportunity from president morse to um
put money into the
pfas fund and i'll go into that just a
little bit um we
i think i guess with my bill a few years
ago established that fund because we saw
the pfas crisis looming and was going to
provide uh funding which we thought
you know grants that could go out to
municipalities for the municipal
wastewater treatment
systems and um of course this is all
assuming at some point we're going to
win the suit against 3m and this will
get all reimbursed to the state and so
on but the important have that fund
and it had been our intent when we set
up that that the way it was going to be
going through
the des that private well owners could
get help from it
and uh there you know that i think there
was a sense last year with some changes
made to it and this to make sure that
that legislative intent is there because
what we're seeing merrimack you know you
name it
um this chemical is the gift that keeps
on giving we're going to be finding our
wells
in lots of places around around the
state so there's an opportunity to
clarify that and then to put 25 million
dollars which the senate president had
secured into that fund so we would have
money as needed
what made this um particularly
opportune was the number of bills we had
coming from the house about merrimack
and about other places and we had to
hold a couple of them because we were
not sure they passed continental muster
and asked for an opinion from the
courts on that but this was not not to
say we did not recognize that we really
need to be able to help out these
communities so it was felt that by
putting this money into the fund that no
matter what was happening those bills
that we have kind of teed something
something up so um
i understand that uh there is an
amendment from des to make a couple of
corrections that were needed and some
technical correction or two um in what
the senate had added so i i think that's
pretty much where we're at mr chairman
uh uh thank you senator uh the question
is that 25 million is that targeted for
the pfas problem it's for the it's going
into the pfas fund which we set up for
these purposes thank you any other
senators like to comment
just like to ask a question because this
isn't in my commerce or judiciary or
other areas that i'm more familiar with
were there any
how many improperly designed systems
were there
that this came to be a problem i know i
read that it took a lot of time for the
department to look into these things but
did they actually have any actual cases
and controversies of improperly designed
septic systems that gave rise for the
spill any of the representatives want to
speak to that representative power
thank you mr chair um
based on the the testimony in the house
policy committee i am unaware of any
improperly designed systems however it
was stated that there
are instances
in which the applications and the specs
are incomplete
and it's lacking information so
therefore the des needs to expend time
and energy to
the lacking information
so what what we were told is um this
occurs in 10
instances approximately per year out of
6 000 applicants
um which is
about 0.2 percent
very good that was quick committee
uh anything to add from the from the
okay um
yes is it representative powell
i had a question mr chair a procedural
question so um
right here in front of me i have two
handouts
and
it's a side by side
to house bill 1293
and
one has more pages than the other and
additionally i i researched this
thoroughly this this weekend
okay
so the information that i was able to um
derive from the docket
um
is different from the information that's
in front of me
so um
i am not aware of a
um
a proportion of this amendment
by the senate
with regard to a pfas fund could some
where where is this in in the amendment
is is this
is this part of the senate amendment or
is this something that the des i'm very
confused uh if i if i may mr chairman um
if you look at the bill as amended by
i think we put that another
bill i'm sorry
remember
it's another bill
yes senator um
in front okay in front of me i have um
an amendment 1825 s
and like i said i i spent a significant
um
amount of time studying this and i
am unaware of that provision my mistake
i
think that we decided at the last minute
to put another in another bill and it is
another bill and
any additional comments from the
from the house side yes
representative power so thank you mr
chair um
from my intense analysis of this
amendment
um
i have a number of concerns with it
additionally i spent
about an hour and a half yesterday
speaking with mr tardif from the
department of environmental
services
seeking to get my questions with regard
unfortunately
as a result of that conversation that
there seemed to be more confusion um
amongst both parties
of particular concern to me is the
proposed changes in section three of the
amendment that pertain to protective
well radii
and um
i also
watched the hearing
in the senate when this amendment was
brought up
and
no
no one from the senate committee
asked about
what happened to
section
um
a colon 30-b
pertaining to cluster development that
is completely
um eliminated from statute so that's
that's i find that very concerning
and furthermore the process
by which this all came about
i understand through my conversation
with the des that
these are important issues that need to
be addressed through legislation
however
this was not
heard in the house policy committee
and
to be clear while it has
the words well and septic
system in it
it
is unrelated to the underlying bill
so
um
i'm not very uncomfortable with um
the content of this amendment
um
senate colleagues do you have any
further discussion you want to add to
that
um
in terms of the
provision a and b i think we might get
some clarification from uh
mr tardive
in terms of um the amendment in the
senate uh this is
what both bodies do is we amend bills
from the other body
and um
that that's why we have committees of
conference
but
you know it is germaine to the bill
because it is now in the in the building
um so that's not unusual for both bodies
to do this
um constantly so
that would be
in terms of the procedural aspects
that's just the way things are for both
bodies
thank you senator
i i
if i may i i understand
and my colleagues can help correct me if
i'm wrong the conversations we've had
with des
drive us to
a preliminary conclusion that this bill
as amended is not ready for prime time
it needs a lot more work done to it
and
and we really
at this point
don't have those amendments
that might need to be done
will need to be considered and then
and then put forth
that this bill might
be
better received
after it goes through some additional
work by des
yes senator
there's an old saying you don't make the
this bill is needed
while we're sitting here pfas is leaking
into wells and expanding its footprint
we have the ability to put money into a
fund to start addressing that
people die
from pfas and other similar things when
you try to make the perfect the enemy of
the good we wind up not being effective
as a legislature
so i would submit that we pass this and
you repair anything in it next year
because very few pieces of legislation
are ever passed
that don't require further modification
as circumstances uh and issues develop
down the road
could you senator could you direct me to
the where in the amendment it talks
but the fund isn't in here that was my
mistake
your point about potential pollution
um and this having needing to deal with
this radii
issue because of people's property
rights
is significant so
in terms of the technical question about
parts a and b i think that's been
answered i thought one of you had an
amendment that was being drafted by oos
um is that the case
yeah
yeah if you if you want mr chairman but
uh please come up and introduce yourself
good afternoon good afternoon my name is
phillip trobridge i'm the manager of the
land resource programs at des
i'm rob tardif i'm the
administrator of the subsurface systems
bureau at des
i've spoken with a few of you folks uh
throughout the past few days on these
amendments
uh the first amendment well
the underlying bill as representative
power pointed out is relative to
uh homeowner designs
for their domicile
that passed the both house and the
senate unanimously so
i'd be happy to speak more to that but i
think the questions really are regarding
the two amendments
uh the first amendment being to 45 a 30
a and 30 b
30 b is
excuse me 30b is really the meat of what
we're talking about
and what we what we ended up trying to
do is to clarify
30b
uh and in the process
we went
through the attorney general's office
and the attorney general's office
determined that the language in third
the existing language in 30b
was such that it should be completely
rewritten to accomplish the
clarifications that we're trying to
accomplish
so in those amendments
um
again the the entire language was
rewritten uh some of the
clarifications and
changes that were made were regarding
different scenarios when it comes to
installation of drinking water private
drinking water wells
in septic systems
for instance if a septic system is
installed concurrently or if a well is
installed concurrently with a septic
system then certain things
would come into play if a well is
installed
without being relative to the
installation of a septic system then
other conditions would come into play we
tried to and i could i'd be happy to get
into those details i'm trying to stay
somewhat general
the other part of the clarification of
38 and 30 b is to
essentially level the playing field
relative to wells installed
prior to 1989 and wells installed
subsequent uh
after 1989.
uh in 1989 well
in 1991 there was some legislation or a
supreme court hearing
uh
regarding a spite well that was
installed that encumbered uh an
undeveloped lot
uh the supreme court decided that the
protective well radius that was going
over
the well owner's property onto the
budding property
could not encumber
that that there or the rights of
the adjacent lot to be developed
so
that eddie well drilled after 1989
the protective well radius on the
abutting lots would be forfeited
what the other part of this bill is to
try to level that playing field such
that wells drilled prior to 1989 uh also
couldn't encumber adjacent lots let me
let me uh jump in for a minute uh i
asked my senate colleagues what i'm
looking at is uh is an amendment 18
25 s is that
is that the one that
you guys have
but it's not yet incorporated is that
right
1825 s i believe is on the docket on the
website as you and i spoke yesterday
there has since been
an amendment
2022-2004-h
uh and in fact
i was speaking with
a matthew young at ols to further
clarify
uh and we're hoping that that additional
clarification which would include
representative powers concerns about
uh the cluster subdivision
provisions that are currently in 45 a 30
b
uh be
reinstated into this amendment we're
hoping to get that language here
uh what what we're proposing to do and
and to to the point you were making
representative power
uh it was determined that that language
should have stayed
in the statute
uh so we're now proposing to keep that
language in the statute so where is that
language right now
again
earlier this afternoon
yes
we're hoping to get it here by this time
through representative mcconkey i spoke
with representative mcconkey this
morning well
around noon
uh and again timing has
been a
real time crunch to try and get this all
done i think i think it goes without
saying that it's it's difficult for us
to consider an amendment that we don't
have i understand
ms johnson mr chairman i thought we i
thought that that was here and that's
why i have my some of my confusion so
yes representatives
i'm sorry to just to be 100 sure 2 0 0 4
h
is not the latest amendment we're
waiting for one more
waiting for one more waiting for one
more okay that's what i just wanted to
be sure of shuffle on paper thank you
representative power you had a comment
no two zero zero four h is what we're
waiting for
i have that
zero zero four eight it wasn't and as i
under if i can
sorry
uh if i can
at least describe as i understand it uh
the reason that this 2004 h has not been
seen on the docket yet is because it
wasn't approved by a committee
so it's not public information so
therefore it's not on the website so
it's preliminary at this point yeah uh
yes i was under the understanding that
the committee would have had copies of
at least this 2004-h because i received
it through email
representative
yes mr chair i'm very concerned with the
process and what's going on there seems
to be a lot of confusion with regards to
what exactly we're talking about what's
in the amendment what's not in the
amendment what amendment's coming what
amendment isn't here
i'm
i'm very
[Music]
concerned and very frustrated
if
if this is something
that that needs to be addressed then i
would recommend
that this senate amendment
be filed as an lsr
and it go through the proper procedure
it goes through the senate and and then
the house or if somebody from the house
wants to file it it goes through the
house and then the senate
i i am very uncomfortable with these
types of substantive changes being done
in the senate and then dealt with them
in the committee of conference by
a small number of legislators
this was not heard in the house
the this
the content of the amendment was not
heard in the house by the house policy
committee i'm very uncomfortable
representative piamonte
uh thank you mr chair i agree with uh
representative powell
uh this uh uh
i would prefer just to drop all the
amendments and uh take the house
position on 1293 has ought to pass
yes representative i i was i've had
conversations with mr tardiff yesterday
i
geeked out a little bit i told him that
admitted that being on a planning board
for 12 15 years however long i've been
on it i understood where we were going
here and the importance of it i
certainly respect what i'm hearing from
my colleagues here also and to that end
i think the underlying bill that we were
talking about roughly designing a system
for your own domicile is important
even for the reasons that we've got
stuff leaking into the you know do we if
it's only 10 it's only 10 but that's 10
leaking
if we could get at least that past we
would have done something and and i
would i would hope maybe we can at least
do that much and then try to try to
relieve the confusion about the other
things and be comfortable about that in
a separate bill so i'm agreeing with
representative piemonte there to uh
uh if that gets us to move along and
wanted to voice that thank you tara if
you hear anything you wanted to add to
that
uh well
there was another portion of the bill
that is uh it's
relative to the subsurface systems
bureau approval process that's
equally important to us would that be an
additional amendment it's included in
this amendment okay
and what that is is it's relative to our
time frames and our ability to request
additional information from applications
that come in that are not uh complete or
there are lacking
all the information we need
the way 45 8 31 is currently written it
says that within a certain time frame
depending on the type of application we
shall approve or disapprove
the
proposal
if we don't do that within certain time
frames then the by law the the
applications are deemed approved
the department is always
interpreted disapproved as
not necessarily approved certainly but
not necessarily denied either and again
we we would put out a request as we call
it a request for more information it's a
letter sent to the applicant let me ask
you something and i don't want to get
you in trouble with uh that's okay the
commission or with uh with my senate
colleagues but
with with all these changes happening
in a matter of uh now a matter of days
are you comfortable
with the
with the amount of time that your staff
has had to re research and understand
this and
recommend to to the legislature what
ought to happen or would you like more
time
uh i think
well i fully appreciate and agree that
it's been quite a crunch to try to get
all this information to
you folks um
i think the
up to
my conversations with matt young today
in ols i think that what's being
proposed and i fully appreciate the fact
that you haven't seen it yet
unfortunately
uh i think it's a pretty complete
package
um
what
relative to the process uh the amendment
well there was a minor tweak to that
because the language that we proposed
not all of the language was included
in
this 22
2004 h
that again we were under the impression
so it would would it be your contention
that the
0 0 4h needs a further amendment or
needs to be adjusted
it's slightly again that the the
language that we suggested in a word
document that we submitted or was
submitted through
representative mcconkey
it seemed as though some of the things
in that were not included
and it's just one does that mean that
that it's pending or does that mean
someone has a homework assignment
tonight so late in the evening
i would i was hoping that it would be on
your desks for this meeting so i i don't
know if it's even a homework assignment
today
yes senator uh thank you mr chairman
so um just to clarify what you're
talking about the rulemaking that is on
the bill as amended by the senate that's
page three
well um
as amended by the senate i think it's
signed 24.
if you'll take a look i just wanted to
ask that because then i have a question
for you mr chairman perhaps the way i
think about it is it's uh section
five
pardon
it's the uh number five of the amendment
okay so nothing okay starting on line 34
okay see the version we have
as it's starting on 29 but
yeah
yeah so representative powers asked you
i had a conversation with mr tardif
yesterday where i pointed out to him
that cluster development had been
dropped by the attorney general's office
the attorney that drafted this amendment
language had i not had that conversation
and brought it to his attention it
wouldn't be
i guess
being
replaced and put back into some
amendment which we don't yet have so my
question is
what else
in this amendment which we don't yet
have what else is is missing what what
what else is may have unintended
consequences
we as i'm sorry we as legislators need
to take a careful review and look at
this language that is our job
and i will repeat yet once again i am
very uncomfortable
with the manner in which
these proposed changes are
are being done
it's it's unacceptable to me
i would
i don't disagree that that perhaps this
this needs to be addressed but let's do
it correctly
we need to do this right
yes sir
so um thank you mr chairman i i
understand what the representative's
saying and i think that's caution is
always good
it seems to me
that what is
relatively simple here is that part
about the
if you look at the bill as amended by
the senate
that version page three
dotted lines 34.
through sections
six
now
this is as we heard
from des is is some necessary
procedural clarifications
the 30 days the 15 days the additional
information you know we do this about a
lot of things it's good to have that
clarified
it seems to me that that doesn't run
into the problems that the
representative is raising about
you know time to cook it
um and i would think that maybe what we
could do is take the underlying bill
and this section forget the rest of it
for now because that obviously
is causing some discomfort
and that might be a way for us to
proceed so can you describe that to me
again slowly yeah sure so we'd have the
underlying bill
portion
right right and then we'd have starting
on line 34
the bill the version as amended by the
senate
so on page
three hb 293 as amended by the senate on
page three starting at lines
and then going online
on page 4 through line 22
so that sections 5 and 6.
so those two sections which are just the
kind of procedural about the fifth the
additional information time period for
review the 30 days and the 15 days so
that people have that
clarification and guarantee that things
will get done in a timely fashion that
that's what the department is asking for
there
i think pretty simple
um so we could do the underlying bill
that part
drop the things that are causing the
difficulties and potential future you
know waiting for other amendments and so
on
representative power
thank you mr chair so to be clear
there is another amendment it's 2004 h
which amends
section 5 that you just referenced
and
com
yeah
comparing
um those two amendments which which i
did over this weekend
um
that that needs to be reconciled yeah i
think it's unfortunate that we senate
members did not receive that
i'm sorry about it
and uh i hope that the next time that
the information will be coming in a
timely fashion from the department
so we can act
appropriately mr turner if you have any
final comments there
uh if i could take just a minute and
again i appreciate everybody's concerned
on on the timeliness here and i
apologize for that
but the potential consequence of not
trying to correct
the procedural language in 45 8 31
is that if we
if we are forced to deem us an
application
disapproved or deny an application
because an applicant doesn't have enough
time to respond to us
that applicant would then have to we
would have no choice but to deny a
deficient application
and the applicant would be forced to
then resubmit the application including
application fees we're trying to avoid
that by allowing us to have
a process in which we can request more
information without formally denying an
application thank you representative
manchuri
thank you mr chair do you have the the
ability to waive application fees or
waive any fees no application fees are
set in stature they're set in statute
yes so okay thank you representative
power thank you mr chair um
when
did you realize that this was an issue
rsa485-a colon 31.
about 20 months ago three weeks ago
we were presented we've been uh dealing
with an application regarding a
condominium conversion
condominium conveyance that didn't meet
our subdivision requirements
by definition by statutory definition
condominium condominium conveyance
requires subdivision approval in order
to obtain subdivision approval you have
to demonstrate lot loading which means
that the
the property can support the proposed
sewage load
in this particular case there are many
older cabins on this small property at
spotford lake
and we've been going back and forth with
the applicant to try to resolve these
issues
they obtained council the council
pointed out this problem that we've had
in
45 831 again the department's
interpretation of disapprove was not
deny the department's
interpretation of disapprove was
not approved not deny request more
information it was pointed out to us
that because we approve
applications
disapprove is synonymous with deny
again that's not the way we've been
doing
our business for 40 years
uh and quite frankly if
well
it is the case right now that
all of these
applications that we haven't formally
approved are now by law
approved
regardless of the
lack of compliance with current statutes
and laws
uh that's that can be a real problem
depending on
the deficiencies of an application we
have to now prove everything
again so
this was brought to our attention about
three weeks ago and we've been trying to
not only draft
proposed language here to fix the
problem but we're also been scrambling
to try and come up with a legitimate way
to
address these deficient applications
again we've we've asked for more
information we haven't received it in 15
or 30 days
you know we've been waiting for for
applicants to respond and maybe it takes
them more time to develop the answers
that we need
but all those applications are now
deemed approved this is targeting
including this condominium convention if
you knew about this
of your agency knew about this
three weeks ago
why are we the last day before this
whole process gets cut off
uh why are we why are we at this point
why couldn't we have done something in
we we well
i guess that's a that's a very good
question i
i guess i'm not familiar enough with the
legislative process to be able to just
change statute i thought
my impression is it takes this process
to go through to change statutory
language representative power
um mr chair i'd like to point out that
if hp 1293 didn't exist
then des wouldn't be
attempting to
address an issue
in this manner
they would
be waiting until the filing period
to file on lsr
or the senate would have put it on a
forum i'm gonna run a bill and you'd be
crazy man that's a good question two
minute recess mr pyramid yes uh uh are
you is the senate ready to go off and
get firm up your position in a small a
oh
well thank you mr chairman i won't speak
for my colleague but say that if if
there was agreement on taking that
procedural part and the underlying bill
i think would be all good to go
if that's not the way we want to go then
we can chat briefly and see what we can
do
so
the concern that i have
is that in the absence of changing
section five and six and adopting that
that the department's only option
for any
project any construction project going
forward in which there's a need for an
exchange of information
their only option is to deny the project
i don't think that's good head work in
the middle of a housing crisis
i think that this language works 2004
doesn't exist i don't have it it's never
been adopted it's never been presented
so as far as i'm concerned that doesn't
exist as an amendment
my concern going forward again is that
the only option that des has to
responsibly perform its functions for
the people of the state is to deny any
application that goes beyond the time
limits
that's the problem that sections five
and six would solve
and that's why i would ask that uh that
we get that language incorporated
thank you mr chair so um to be clear
your the statement that you just made
you're referencing the amendment 1825 s
so um
while i
understand
your your point the point that i would
make is that there's
further amendments
which fix that so the problem is with
with the the wording in 1825
s
is that it's insufficient there's
there's problems with it and it's the
language as written in that amendment is
not going to accomplish what the des
needs it to do
yes well that's why i suggested if you
were to take what what does in that
the mythical 2024 to whatever it is 2004
amendment and and uh you know rewrite
what we got here with that language we
could vote on that today
yes representative so thank you mr chair
so
it's the same
response my understanding is that
there's an additional amendment which
further changes
2004 h that we don't yet have is that
the case
sorry um
we actually looked at that there was
very some very very minor changes that
aren't necessary so in other words that
that what you have there
would be
what we could do but if we can't do it
okay uh any further
comments
yes representative power could
could mr tardif
comment on
on that remark that was just made
because email was removed and then there
was some other language that was as such
that needed to be
put in
and i thought that that was very key to
clarifying what what was
being asked
of when you were asking for additional
information in order for this language
to be tight so i contend that we in fact
do need need it
that language we're waiting for
the uh relative to the amendment 2004 h
12 11 and 12 where it says and deemed
administratively complete
uh that is in reference only to a
septic system application a sewage a
waste disposal system application
when we uh proposed the amendment we
were hoping that that same term
uh at the end of line seven where
it says fees are received
it doesn't include the term and deemed
administratively complete the difference
as far as the administratively complete
if i could just take a second
support staff who looks at every
application that comes into lrm
including the subsurface systems bureau
and they go through a very
cur a very brief administrative
uh completeness check for the subsurface
system bureau applications that would
include things like it you know that the
plan has a designer stamp the fee is
accurate
uh there's a tax map and lot number it's
not a technical review
so what we're intending by inserting
this and deemed administratively
complete phrase
is that the actual 15 and 30 day
technical review time frames wouldn't
start until it was deemed
administratively complete for instance
if
if during the administrative
completeness process they find that a
designer forgot to put their designer
stamp on the plan and we send it back
say hey you forgot your designer stamp
something that simple if they don't get
it back to us in 15 days
we have to deny it the way it is now so
we're trying to
only include
the technical review process
is it senator one last comment please
yeah so i guess the question is that if
we were to add that phrase at line seven
as indicated we would have that of that
of that language would be the language
that is the
is what satisfies and if you would agree
and uh
then the underlying bill we could vote
on that
uh comments from the
committee on uh
that no that's uh
we
asked just a little more definition uh
is it do you have a line
one to 17 type of uh
way to point pinpoint it in the uh
well i guess what we're saying
and you could maybe take your copy and
write it in where you want it and do it
canadian up here yeah
that that's what we would have
and that would be for reference of any
potential
consideration representative pia mate
thank you mr chia i i don't know
maybe it's me but i think this thing is
way out of control okay
the underlying bill is the house
position
i'm voting for that
i i think uh
the position that we we are
uh
solidifying around is the fact that
uh there's a lot of good stuff in the
underlying bill
however
uh when we're
not comfortable that it hasn't been
properly vetted
in either the house
or des i think this
i think you guys would
although you probably can't say it
you guys would like more time
to scrub this
set of documents
respectfully is that we would ask that
you
three ascend to
i think i need to reiterate the fact
that what that's going to do to the
process
is basically force des to deny any
permit that exceeds the time limitations
which is virtually every permit that has
any kind of required additional
information
to be submitted
in the midst of a housing crisis
okay and so i will not support that
position
okay and any other firm further comments
okay okay yes
thank you mr chair and i i
i'm absolutely there and as i'm
understanding this you know
either somebody in a black robe came up
with uh you know who found this or or
somebody uh you know attorneys found
this and and i worry about language uh
and and uh i agree i would wan i want
section five to be added my concern is
similar then to my colleagues
that if we miss something here
we you know if this is if this is coming
through this quickly and we miss
something here then we're going to go
half back and fix it later i i'm
i'm just
i'm very reticent to say i i support my
house position but i do because i really
want this part to be added to that but
i'm just concerned thank you
okay that concludes the if i might mr
chair one more remark briefly okay
thereby delaying for one year at least
any
application that requires additional
information which isn't submitted within
the 15 or 30 day time frame
understand the consequence unintended or
otherwise and i think that
the correction requested
by the department for that very narrow
scope giving them the the ability
to do something other than deny is not
unreasonable and i would ask the house
to consider that thank you thank you yes
thank you mr chair um
my comment to that would be
then therefore
applicants should
ensure that their applications are in
fact complete and have all the
information
then there won't be any problems
if i might mr chair with all due respect
have you reviewed any of the
applications that come into des some of
these complicated systems for for
condominium complexes and so forth
there's a lot of back and forth that
goes on that used to go on
until some lawyer or judge decided the
language wasn't quite right
so now we stop the entire process
of of approving or
allowing des and the applicant to
communicate
because of some reason that is as of yet
unclear to me
this is not anything difficult this is
not anything abstruse
this is a very simple clarification that
enables the department to do its job we
are stopping the department from doing
the job for the people of the state of
new hampshire if we don't pass the
language of 2004 as amended by mr
tardiff well let me say that uh and this
will be the end of it uh our offer still
is on the table
thank you the uh
the committee of conference
okay we're going to try to continue our
conference on hb 1397. we have i see two
okay
oh
um
it's just it's a request for a recess
till tomorrow at some point
i'm sure the speaker would be glad to
that's what we're going to have to do if
some of these can't make it
nice
the reason i'm asking for a recess is so
that i can speak to the senate president
about this
i respect
you but i will
recess
this
temporarily recess this committee
chance
okay
just to clarify the language we're not
taking a
you